please whatever guys does body count
matter if you never find out
I'd never asked yeah I'm the same way
too I always say you're not gonna get
the truth
just now and even if you got a hint of
you getting the truth you still have a
link is the truth so it just don't don't
even bother asking if you like her for
whatever reason then just go ahead and
go with it because you might get your
feelings hurt that's what I've heard
from most guys it's like they just don't
even want to know I mean at that at that
point
now it's a different story if you're out
there walking around and you got a
couple guys every now and then in the
same city like yeah
who's that guy
he's the [ __ ] smashed let me Smash If
you keep hearing that [ __ ] then it's
like oh now you've been forced into
knowing the body count but most women
are going to tell you
it's true I don't want another body
count I'm never gonna ask yeah it's
never a number you want to hear
it what if it's zero
because that's not true
I mean she could be like a 20 year old
you know I've had a 29 year old chick
tell me she had only had sex with two
people and not to this day I find that
hard to believe she looks good too so no
um I get mad at 19. so
um so it's it's a little different for
me when we met each other we were each
other so it's a little different but
what about like like
I'm sure you have friends you hear
stories I tell them you should know
about this okay okay like there was
nothing worse than a guy you know you
hey guys he got my girl guys I want to
introduce you and your boy's like oh
that's your girl right there's nothing
worse than it especially if you guys are
in the same city you got to know these
things because you don't want to be no
man wants to be embarrassed you know
that they're running out the man gonna
smash that girl so to me it's very it's
very important what do you think guys
can get the truth from girls
you can look at behaviors
but if she don't like she's on Instagram
and everything is always out or she's
always got some random messages and
stuff you kind of look at behaviors and
even if she hasn't done that she's
presenting herself like she is and
that's to me that's that's still as bad
as well
I said that's a good point
girl with a little
has a little body comp but she's over
sexualizing herself on social media is
that the same thing or would you like
let that pass I still think she's lying
yeah yeah if it was I would say it's
some type of insecurity there that's the
reason why that yeah but as to why she's
why she's showing she may not have a
high body count but I think it's it's
something do you find I mean most of the
girls that I know that sexualize
themselves on social media they do sleep
around do you find that's not the case
oh I don't know no okay you don't know
anyone that does that no I'm always on
volleyball teams like there's always one
I think uh women like attention so not
necessarily they don't necessarily have
to be give up the trials and again we
will never know if they are but I think
women like attention like to seek the
validation especially with social media
being out there
everybody want to follow the followers
and the likes
what do you guys think you think guys
can find out about that stuff or no you
think it's like worth their time to ask
I feel like it does nothing
I'm gonna add this too real quick I
think it's uh it could be insecurity on
the man's part too and I think women May
view that as an insecurity so why are
you concerned I mean just imagine you
asking about every little thing who's
who you texting who's all the guys in
EDM how many people you want to smash
it's just like a pattern that just don't
even ask don't even bother don't even
matter no other man should matter if
you're in the picture and if you if you
focus on everything else that she got
going on that she's going for you a
certain type of way but what if she's a
304
I guess you're gonna have to you're
gonna have to vet and analyze that at
that point I mean I don't think 304 has
just got it walking around with a 304
knee on the hit so I think you're gonna
have to just put together the context
clues without accent without asking
without asking her like her body cone
you just have to observe her behavior
yeah because you because you'll never
know
um and and I think it's some guys out
there that's married to three or fours
and they don't even know to this day so
I just think it's impossible to figure
out so you want to just bet the best way
you can and hope for the best
what do you think I agree yeah yeah I I
agree with that I gotta I gotta stir
this year so yeah I agree with that so
like you never to me
for most women they're not going to tell
because they've been taught to a woman
never Tails right so they're not going
to tell but you can observe their
patterns and if to me if their patterns
don't match what you want don't even
waste your time but you could be
throwing off with the pattern too so
that's why I just think you're just
still not gonna never know I mean they
got hoes they got tight cats so it's
still not going
you can't even tell that way
I I think girls telling themselves
eventually I think at some point like
you don't think if you're married to a
girl for like five years you're not
gonna get some including if she was in
the streets for 10. it's definitely
behaviors you could see yeah always what
behaviors do you guys look for she's too
friendly with men that's the number one
she can't cook because the ultimate
Telltale sign she can't cook she was out
there that's just that's what I believe
it's like she's gonna take it on dates
like she doesn't have to pay for dinner
in 10 years
uh
I would say if she's
if she's putting on my [ __ ] and she
pulled off my clothes
you know as soon as you're getting that
she throwing my [ __ ] off I'll be like
damn like how many times you've done
this [ __ ] so um I would say that and
then I think the acts that they're doing
too they look like they're doing it too
damn good awesome porn [ __ ] it's like
man
you showing up ain't you
what kind of footage you got out here
oh god
um yeah
I don't know I think
I feel bad for guys nowadays to be fair
like I think that's like
I don't know I don't like I have
brothers I don't even know how I would
tell them to like bet a girl because I
feel like I don't know some like I think
we could all think of a girl that like
you just would never know you know
I'm gonna take something that I just
picked up uh not too long ago is
I want to know the relationship that she
has with her father absolutely I think
that's one of the most important thing
and I didn't even realized
how important it was until until now
because I know somebody that's like that
it's a complete difference it's a the
respect
um like the Loyalty like knowing how to
uh you know cater to a man and Cadence
not a bad thing right but just knowing
how to
like support your man is different when
the father's been active in their life
so I think that's one of the things that
I would tell my sons to do and I would
advise that any man that's watching this
right now see what type of relationship
they have with their father
what do you guys think of the statement
men want to be praised for basic
treatment
those are the same women that say they
don't do wife duties their girlfriends
yeah or they I don't want to be your mom
those are the same people saying this I
think they're irrelevant what are basic
what are basic things
I don't know I just got this from what
are basic things I know you know can you
repeat the question
um what do you think of the statement
when men want to be
what do you think of the statement men
want to be praised for basic treatment
what are basic things like if they're
taking out the trash
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible